you want to find me a chat anytime
anyplace
don't worry we got a security guard
drama drama drama last night off that's
the red I mean it's what we've come to
expect from that boy chatting happened
last night when all the Bachelorette men
got together and chat I mean he went
after everybody I mean everybody and our
lauren zima was there to reveal all the
drama I get it and see on TV dams you
might wanna pump your brakes there buddy
I got dirt on you son don't make me talk
about your drill bro alright Chad didn't
disappoint calling people out saying
some weird stuff sometimes you choose
apples but you should've shows pickles
you know me but his most shocking move
didn't make the cut what you didn't see
was a private moment between Chad and
Chris Harrison during the commercial
break Chad took the opportunity to lean
over and tell Chris he was really sorry
for what went down during bachelor in
paradise so it must have been something
big
Chris accepted the apology though told
Chad it's all good and it may have
something to do with this Nicki you're
making this a lot worse than it needs to
be you went to sleep last night with a
mimosa and a robe on you Chris Harrison
the mother things you didn't see during
the Mintel all special in Chad's honor a
tray of deli meats was passed around for
the audience to snack on and in that
audience was Bachelor superfan actress
Chloe grace Moretz now the guys on the
other hand were given shots of fireball
to give them a little liquid courage for
the taping but things still got really
tense when Chad called out JoJo's final
two men
Robbie broke up with his girlfriend days
before filming in order to be on the
show with you and we both know that
Jordan is a liar cheater who's an older
brother won't even talk to them oh I
could go off right now he's not even
worth my breath
speaking of Jordan's brother Aaron the
NFL quarterback finally broke his
silence about the strain within his
family telling reporters at training
camp he buys talking publicly about
family matters inappropriate but he did
wish brother Jordan well in the quote
competition
you